despite the setback in Parliament the
demonstrators in Kyiv are vowing to
continue their protest until the
government goes if the government
disregards the will of the people it's
an illegitimate regime we need to form
our own government that will respect our
rules and our right to vote via pro in
the long road ahead of the afternoon
vote the mood in the parliamentary
chamber was inflamed supporters and
opponents of the government confronted
each other
opposition leader vitali klitschko
accused the prime minister of governing
the country against the will of the
people with an anti EU policy speech at
four masala Madhu they've taken away our
hope of living in a modern country and
when Ukrainians demonstrated peacefully
he sent in the riot police to crack down
on the protests with force we've not
seen anything like this since
independence attempts by the prime
minister to calm the situation were
shouted down by the opposition virtue I
would like to apologize for the actions
of our security forces against
demonstrators at Independence Square he
made a plea for dialogue but warned that
the country has the resources to stamp
out any violence but the thousands
gathered in central kiev were unmoved by
the warning they want change